and lastly I'm going to pass this over
to my friend Kevin because we lost one
of the stars of clerks and it was sad to
everyone who knew Lisa spoon our Lisa
spoon our plate Kaitlyn in clerks the
girl that got away the one that dante
pines after the one who eventually has
sex with a dead guy in the bathroom i
was i want to do i want to bury the lead
on that one yeah she comes that thing
that was the best ever isn't and she and
her performance is pretty it's great
sounding um Lisa was one of the chief
architects of clerks Jason Mewes of
course is my dear friend and we do a lot
of [ __ ] together but he came in to like
work on the days that he worked and he
was too busy like partying at that age
so it was me Brian O'Halloran a Jeff
Anderson and least a spoon our the for
cast members kind of rehearsing for a
month before anybody got out there to
shoot and stuff and when I heard that
she passed away I know she'd been sick
in the past but when I heard she passed
away the first thing I was thunderstruck
by I was like Fox she dreamed my dream
for me and with me and we built
something together and how I met her was
I didn't know or like a lot of people in
clerk's you know I grew up with or have
known you know for years but we had
auditions at the First Avenue Playhouse
in Atlantic islands and meet we got
Brian O'Halloran out of that and Marilyn
Gigliotti
played Veronica Jeff Anderson as well
but I knew him from the video store he's
come in also I knew him from high school
but we couldn't find a Caitlin and
Caitlin needed to be like you know the
one that captured his heart and so she
had to be a stunner comes in late in the
picture so she's got a lot of catch up
to do she's like the shark and John they
talk about of the whole movie and on see
her until left the third act night so
didn't find her in the auditions nobody
came in that felt like it so I said you
know I'm gonna go to Brookdale Community
College where I used to go salad for
your school it's like a two-year school
you get an associate's degree and I take
an acting class there so I knew that
acting classes so I'm like I'm gonna go
watch an acting class at Brookdale went
to Brookdale and picked an acting class
sat in the back of the room
and there is about 20 kids and they were
partnered up doing scenes man Lisa and
this guy get up and do scene and she was
like crazy natural I don't know how to
describe it but she seemed real everyone
else smelled like they were acting you
know the trick to acting is basically
you have to deliver those lines as if
you are thinking of them for the first
time as if you're having an authentic
conversation that is being generated off
the top of your head and the trick is
that you've memorized this whole thing
you know exactly what you're going to
say and she heard delivery with that
natural but it felt like I thought she's
just she's having a real conversation so
I said that's her and so I waited till
after class and then I followed her back
to her car in the park
Oh Lord so true now that I look back I'm
like thank God I ain't good mate so I
followed her out to her car and then I
said excuse me and she turned around
looked at me word and I said this is
going to sound really creepy but would
you like to be in a movie and she looks
at me up and down she goes not if it's
porn
we're wearing a trench coat and I was I
was off so I said it's not it's not I
said I got a script in my car and I
remember she goes all my life and I
remember she goes well I'm not going
there and I said no I owned by Ted Bundy
and look can you help me carry this
couch in the van away will she bring fix
that person a problem so uh so she I go
to my car get the script I give it a
scrip for clerks it's like a hundred and
sixty pages full of dick jokes set in
the convenience store and I was like hit
your wagon to this star so I gave it to
her in a Roman number I said like read
it if you like it call me and and and
like I would love you to be in and she's
okay got in the car and left and you
know I figure out where the chances I
hear from her again two days later she
called me and I was like oh my god woody
what do you think and she goes well it's
certainly not porn
but everybody talks like it is
and she goes it's funny do you think
you'd get away with this and I was like
yeah I think who's gonna stop us and
she's like I am in so there's someone
that barely knew did she lived in New
Jersey she lived in like free all the
town so she was within 45 minutes where
I grew up and [ __ ] I had no idea who she
was
sar and said please do this movie she
said yes and that woman became one of
the most important people I'd ever meet
in my life I think about her no [ __ ]
at least once a day because at least
once a day in my life I think about
clerks and not where I'm sitting around
jerking off going thank God it happened
I'm so good oh my god I was so smart one
but because like it comes up it's just
it's the Keystone amount the same way
like being married comes up or having a
kid comes up clerks is big part of my
DNA and when I talk about it or when I
see it their posters are my house and
[ __ ] she's standing right next to me in
the poster you know I'm not going to say
like we were the Beatles the five of us
but the five of us on the poster were
the brain trust of that movie I was just
a guy that wrote a script but I needed
them to bring it to life and she came in
first first day of shooting we rehearsed
that movie for like a month straight at
quick stop after hours from like 10:30
at night till about 3:00 4:00 in the
morning [ __ ] so that when we did it we
could do it and all in one take like a
play we weren't burning very severe it
takes burning a lot of footage so day
one first thing we shoot is a Maryland
bronica finding out Randall in the video
store that Dante's cheated on her so
it's a quick scene with those two a
water and but you know it's maybe a half
page scene we did that got two takes we
look great moving on the next thing we
shoot is the seven-minute take of Lisa
and and Brian who plays Dante having
their whole big conversation is the
first time you see her in the movie it's
the first time you're hearing anything
about her side of the story right so
they come in we rehearse it to death and
stuff they came in and do it
seven-minute take they'd never [ __ ]
drop the ball they sound like they're
having a conversation but some of the
most stylized gymnastic [ __ ] oriented
dialogue a human tongue will ever have
to do and they dropped it in [ __ ] one
take we did a backup take for the [ __ ]
of it but we
use it it was the first take and now
that that's what's in the [ __ ] movie
and to this day you know that happened
25 almost 25 years ago to this day I've
shot a bunch of things that is one of
the things I'm most proud of having done
as a director not because it shows off
any [ __ ] panache for me as a director
it really doesn't because it's a [ __ ]
two shot that doesn't move but it shows
that those kids who were not pros they
hadn't trained the whole [ __ ] live
she went to a couple acting classes
maybe she acted in high school Brian had
done some community theater but they got
up and I was like I don't have any money
so please do it right the first time and
they a no predator Larry trusted yeah
and and so she's a big part of my life
and and you know she didn't really go on
with acting she went home at one point
she liked her and Jeff we're together
well while we were making the movie God
plays Randall they met and kind of fell
in love and so they were together for a
few years and they got married and
eventually split up but remained really
great like friends so she went back to
Jersey and she got married she had a
daughter named Mia and every time I
talked to her on Facebook that was his
love of her life she talked about me and
the immune so and how much she wanted to
be there for because her health was
always in jeopardy I don't know if it
was a cancer something I know this much
at one point she'd gotten so many
radiation treatment therapies that her
organs had fused together Oh Lord
so she was always in [ __ ] pain and
she looked fine from the surface one of
these cases of people that like you look
great but they're like but I'm [ __ ]
dying inside she was always they said
for the past ten years she had been
battling chronic illness a big time but
she fought it to stay with her kids like
she was as wonderful as an actress as
she is and she is in that movie man like
I've gone on do some other things but
like that performance is [ __ ] killer
she was a far better mother but she's
the first of our world to kind of go and
she went way too [ __ ] early dude
forty for one of the most generous
people I met and as much as she met a
total stranger some fat boy came up to
her in a parking lot and gave her like a
half-assed proposition and she trusted
me and kind of went with it and we will
all went on this [ __ ] journey
together I'll miss her
all the time there's a there's a dress
she she's a big believer if she'd gotten
over this health thing she was going to
start up this patient advocate
foundation because she gotten some bad
advice early on that if she had a hard
time the medical professionals that
worked with her yes nobody believed her
when she was like it's this it's this so
in her memory her brother is asking
people to go to just giving calm look
for the patient advocate foundation you
can kind of donate money and her name
you look under spoon our to I think you
can also choice a spoon yeah yeah man it
was without her nothing happens you know
what I'm saying like I'm still the dude
working there could be news story going
would be great to make a movie one day
she was an essential [ __ ] element and
we talk about the why not people in your
life ago say yeah why not let's do this
thing you know then and she was
definitely one of those peachy and I
know it was hard for you it was but his
way tougher for her I'll be honest with
you she had bad bad health for years I'm
[ __ ] fair you know it's one of those
things where you're like can somebody
help her and you realize the limits of
Technology like we always assume
technology will save us if you're sick
somebody's going to make you better but
there's only so much [ __ ] we can do yeah
and some things can't be fixed and she
sadly couldn't be fixed as Kevin
mentioned she was married to Jeff
Anderson briefly played Randall in the
film and here's a little scene that's
from the two of them together which I
always thought was pretty [ __ ]
charming when she shows up and Randall's
watching porn and they have a little
conversation and it runs a while so it
on timers it so just a brief little clip
but certainly worthwhile saying goodbye
to her on screen from her work from
clerks who's Lisa's food our pal Randal
graves charged as a video renter ladies
and gentlemen miss Asian design made
yourself
Caitlyn Marie you saw that article got
isn't it awful my mother sent that in I
take it she likes the guy you'd think
she's marrying him what are you watching
children's programming what'd your mom
say when you told her you weren't
engaged anymore she said not to come
home until after graduation what
you got thrown out for Don today what
can I say he does weird things to me oh
good I watch you can hold me down can I
join in you might be let down I'm not a
hermaphrodite thank you are hey if you
are huge positive when yeah can I please
[Applause]